wow
i got my virginity back from just
watching this they've watched our video
and it's now cancelled out the sex that
they have had retroactively
we were in a video earlier this year
having a chat about what's better
marvel or dc and so now it's time to
read out some lovely comments that were
left on our lovely video
this wasn't fair marvel seemed like a
casual fan
but dc seemed like he went to college at
dc university or something
uh thank you is all i'm gonna say
michael how do you feel about this
because he's saying that you're just
a casual fan like you're just someone
you're like the one night stand of comic
book information it feels very insultive
because i actually have my own show
i agree so i have a show talking about
coin books and stuff
clearly you don't know your background
knowledge so you know what first of all
i'm gonna give you a cap because you've
got recognition from our clout
definitely secondly i'm gonna say this
you are right though i'm not going to
lie like dirty casual
pro like huh
no that's an it's called an aside in the
industry if there's you're not going to
okay cool you're a swine that's what i'm
saying yeah sorry to all pigs out there
wtf why are you so nerdy bro because i
read
i read i don't know about you but i read
so you
scumbag i'm saying it now i'm calling
you out you mofo
you jabroni i read michael took that
very personally
as if it was specifically about him uh
which means that i can almost pretend
it's nothing to do with me
so yeah don't talk about michael like
that he's not your bro
i'm not your bro it's not your bro bang
yeah
wow
sex and always cool but have you ever
had a satisfactory comic
level discussion why even mention
talking about sex and everything
oh it's like a meme thing on the
internet sex is cool but have you ever
had
a banoffee pie with a tara masala i
don't you know stuff like that like it
you know
it's a it's a thing but uh have you ever
had a satisfactory comic level
discussion i agree
have have you ever had one because i
have had one you're talking about sex or
comic books comic books not six bro
yeah because i mean i've done both full
non full disclosure
wow i got my virginity back from just
watching this
what does that mean i mean think about
the sheer literal sense of that so this
so this person they've watched our video
and it's now
cancelled out the sex that they have had
retroactively so your stuff is that bad
first of all that's terrible
i feel sorry for you yeah definitely we
have robbed you of the sex that you have
had in your life because clearly it was
bad
he's got he's got 2k likes 2.1 000 likes
20 do you think the 26 replies were just
people being like how do i do this
unpopular opinion the whole with prep
time batman could is a stupid argument
there's a lot of geniuses in marvel yeah
batman won't beat them
with prep time we're bro we're playing
with prep time he wouldn't eat them he
won't beat them
with prep time bruce wayne will take out
god himself
that same exact statement could be used
for anyone
i'm gonna pause here absolutely could
not be used for me okay give me like
seven months prep time
and i will still do absolutely all ask
any of my a-level coursework
uh my favorite bit of this is give
anyone enough prep time
and they can win michael
given enough prep time do you think you
could have ever won that debate against
me
that's fine we'll we'll cut here i
apologize to the internet
for having been the harbinger of prep
time as a concept
it's a very light and easy way to make
sure batman wins your argument for you
can't beat god you still cannot beat god
that can't be god yeah um oh you meet
that now
uh uh they're gonna edit that out
that's fine
so bootleg post malone thinks batman can
take out galactus
seems pretty unlikely uh the hum hums
really
uh uh settled that for me uh christmas i
like the fact these are
bootleg posts i actually like
i'm i'm quite happy with this because
like
when that video came out i hadn't had a
haircut in like two and a half years i
was going for like a jesus
bootleg post malone kind of look
batman by the way uh could take out
galactus uh with prep time so there you
go thanks a lot
and joker is a great villain only
because of heath ledger
come on stop idolize the character
himself
if it's not heath we would still prey on
dancing with the devil on a moonlight
what else dc have penguin it's
ridiculous supposed to be penguin not
ping but okay
leave me leave me okay very passionate
guy green goblin red skull
octopus mysterio hunter our villains
are known by everybody man why wouldn't
they put me
on the table instead of that guy who
couldn't say a word against this
simpsons comic book
lads i'm right here exclamation mark
exclamation mark scott i've got this one
yeah thank you so much great go for it
this guy here you're referencing heath
leisure and you referencing something
from batman 89
clearly you don't read the books you
don't read at all and
it is craving the hunter not hunter let
me correct you right there this is
these are pure reasons why you're not on
the show that's what you're not showing
your face
you know what stick to making your
comments because that's what you're good
at i mean he's not
oh by the way simpson's comic book guy
love him small business owner
wish he listed all the villains that
were just the heroes in dark
does anyone know what he was talking
about i found that interesting
most marvel villains are just dark
versions of the hero
so like even if you want to go with mcu
i can list off to you the amount of mcu
movies
where in the first movie the bad guy at
the end of it is just the good guy
in a dark costume the iron manga in iron
man 1 is just a bad guy in an iron man
suit killmonger
in black panther fantastic villain one
of the best is again just a bad guy in a
black panther suit
captain america red skull is just a bad
guy but with the super serum and a weird
red clearly face so like yeah it's a
trope
um nothing that you would criticize too
harshly the films have done rather well
but uh does anyone know what he was
talking about i found that intro oh my
god it's complimentary i just realized
does anyone realize what he was talking
about i found that interesting you're my
guy how many likes
i said zero likes and zero maybe you're
not my guy you have very low clout
can't we like both
yes uh you know what so for the year
because my favorite superhero was
actually the flash but yeah i was on
team marvel so
yeah yeah we can like both cold light a
day enjoy both
love them both yeah all flavors
fantastic but like it does
it is fun every now and then to just be
like you know what do you think is
better yeah that's fine there's room for
everything
well first i want to say thank you for
those that made comments i had a fun
time
creating that video with scott it was
great fun yeah and rest assured
that we are both fantastic we're both
very happy
uh and uh ultimately the video has
brought us nothing but more sex than
we've
been having as as discussed yeah
i'm gonna go because clearly there's
someone in trouble
i don't know about you guys but tata for
now scott
i'm gonna see you again bro um well i
need to get one of these installed in my
home first and then you can come over
it's okay guys okay can you start take
this rack off for me because i need to
go
i'm literally gonna change my display
picture to comical guy tonight
100 oh dear god
i didn't know we were supposed to bring
props no i'm not even wearing anything
coming from
there you had to go on public transport
with this bro i know if we were supposed
to bring props i would have bought like
talent or something good
oh sorry